okay cry now now you're gonna cry
ready cry
what are five things the director should
never do on set yell
unless it's action yeah but even then
do you need to yell it
are you going to rattle the actors right
before they're supposed to act
i don't know i'm all about the quiet
action
uh that line readings don't do that
um just don't don't just
just be specific with the actors don't
be like okay cry now
now you're gonna cry ready
cry give them something okay explain the
situation
like actors want you to explain the
situation to them rather than
give them the result i think that's key
um
don't over shot list that's another
thing
like you in the beginning you tend to do
that and you like you really want to
know what you're
like the main things you all want to
show up and i want to know what i'm
doing and i want
everyone to see that i've got my [ __ ]
together and you tend to
overcompensate with the shot list but
you got to let go of that
and i find that like i don't even do it
anymore because i found like the best
way
like for the way i work is to come in
let the actors do their rehearsal and
then block
and block according to what they do and
you'll still find that it's
it it's similar to what you envisioned
but you're not like okay we're going to
do close-up medium
up over the shoulder around the side
master shot four takes of that which
you'll never use you know what i mean
and it doing that it makes your day go
faster
as well and it's just better for
everyone
so that's three um
you storyboard i don't know how to draw
i wish i knew how to draw i would but no
i've never done that
so so three so okay
but it sounds like you you feel out a
lot of situations intuitively
and so you don't necessarily always plan
things
because things are going to change all
the time on the film set all sorts of
stuff's going to happen
people are going to not show up maybe
they're going to show up they're having
a bad death it's
all just different things are going to
happen right right
i mean plan but don't you know leave
room for
yourself to to work should be in the
flow
you